lobbying us about foresight but  anticipating your opponent's moves he's  your enemy now advising countermeasures  how the hell does she manage that you're  a piece of work Elizabeth  I was hired to win I use whatever  resource I have  you want to lead the fight on gun  control he's over five million of us and  we're are start an inquisition they will  throw you in jail for contempt of  Congress winner  lots one step ahead of the opposition we  have to make it personal you know the  word annihilate it means reduce to  nothing  this is more important than my career is  more important you cross the line  genius and completely unbelievable it's  about making sure you surprise them and  they don't surprise you  you think they treat you like a friend I  mean you think it's normal for friends  to lock each other in cages what would  you do if I recommended that you should  not be allowed to leave